sur les écrans mercredi le dernier gang
un film d'ariel zeitoun qui retrace la
saga du fameux gang des postiches ses
membres avaient défrayé la chronique
dans les années 80 en braquant des
banques déguisé le film est librement
inspiré de la vie d'andré bellaïche le
cerveau présumé du gang que nathalie et
terre et laurence ou rencontrés et que
tout début des années 80 on a volé
qu'aux riches en temps les mecs devenir
riche et populaire à la fois ou signés
pas tout de suite en cinq ans 1300
coffre-fort pillées en plein jour par
des braqueurs grimés et déguisés en fait
j'aime les uniformes est formaté cette
bande
on l'a appelé le banc des postiches il a
dit j en oublie qu'à l'esprit social
jean person who is big east side j'avais
les faits dans les journaux c'était mais
je ne connaissais pas le l'intérieur du
gong est en fait j'ai eu la possibilité
de connaître l'intérieur du gang lorsque
j'ai rencontré andré bellaïche à sa
sortie de prison qu'il avait toujours
été reconnu qu enfin plutôt désigné
comme ayant été le cerveau du gang
aujourd'hui andré bellaïche à 57 cents
et une vie rangée mais ces années de
braquages et de cavale ont largement
inspiré la trame du film simon alias
vincent elbaz grand dit à belleville
montrent le gang et tombe amoureux d'une
jeune femme qui ne le quittera jamais
comme une chanson du milliard de se
revoir bonjour moi parce qu'il est comme
ça suffit comme ça ce qu'on doit jamais
de son histoire d'amour comme de ce
passé mouvementé
andré bellaïche parle avec pudeur et
sincérité me montrer nos origines
c'est votre petite bande
faye a commencé là on était quand même
des laissés pour compte et même laissés
pour compte en a trouvé notre compte
dans cette vie donc on a dû se débattre
tout seul sans l'aide de personne
puisque tout ce qu'on a pu obtenir
on l'a obtenue par le vol je peux pas
rester dangereux tu peux parler je
t'aime plus c'est rare qu'on voit
vraiment je pense que fin à la vie de
couple comme ça d'un de ce genre de mec
de ce genre de deux personnes qui dans
la société font des choix de vie
violente et rares sont ceux qui s'en
sortent
andré bellaïche aidé en cela il n'était
pas présent lors de l'ultime braquage
sanglant cette fois du gang des
postiches raconté